hello there i'm gav this video is
sponsored by omaze we all perceive time
at pretty much the exact same rate to us
an hour is an hour a minute is a minute
and a second is about this long
all of the slow motion footage on this
channel is played back at 25 frames a
second the majority of it shot at 1000
frames a second if you take a thousand
divided by 25 you get 40. we're
stretching one second into 40 seconds of
slo-mo footage the new phantom tmx 7510
allows us to shoot insane frame rates at
actually quite a reasonable resolution
something quite mathematically magical
happens when you shoot at exactly 90 000
frames a second if you divide that by 25
you get 3600 seconds which just turns
out to be exactly one hour 90 000 frames
a second playback at 25 stretches one
second to be an hour long but in the
past using older cameras 90 000 frames a
second would have required an image
about this big filming this video has
left me with literally days worth of
playback so i'm going to be speeding up
just to ramp through the footage and
then slowing down to the speed where one
second equals one hour so just so you
know when we're at that speed i'll shove
a little thing on the footage in the
bottom corner because otherwise this
video would be about three weeks long
and nobody wants that why don't we take
a look at the world where one second
lasts an hour
thank
you at this speed a minute would last
two and a half days
an hour would last about five months
[Music]
and a day would come in at just under a
decade at 9 years and 10 months
should we keep going a month would last
around three centuries
and a year
would be about 3597
years
[Music]
[Music]
if you perceive time at this rate but
your body aged as it usually would
a good innings would give you around 300
000 years
of perceived time
[Music]
[Music]
turn
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
um
me
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
well there we have it a very different
video there but i do think the concept
of that one is so cool just to perceive
time it's such a different scale but at
a unit that we can relate to it's very
very weird looking footage isn't it if
you're interested in seeing one of those
seconds stretched to an hour completely
uncut i've uploaded a video to our
second channel simply titled falling
into a pool for an hour
you don't really need any other
explanation than that does exactly what
it says on the tin that was more focused
around liquids and just things around
the house but if you want a slightly
more extreme version i can always make a
part two to this series just let me know
in the comments if you find it
interesting
oh it is warm in here i need to invest
in some sort of air conditioner
hopefully you enjoyed that video now i'd
love to tell you about the sponsor of
this video omaze omaze is a fundraising
platform that helps raise money for
non-profits and charities by offering
sweepstakes and chances to win
once-in-a-lifetime experiences and
prizes we've partnered with omaze on
this video to offer you the chance to
win a tesla model s plaid
an entire car
taxes and shipping are included for all
u.s residents but the best thing of all
every single donation benefits a great
cause reverb reverb is a non-profit
organization right up my alley they work
with musicians and festivals and venues
in order to make the entire thing much
more green reducing carbon emissions
through their music climate revolution
campaign their work has removed over a
hundred and eighty thousand tons of
carbon dioxide talk about what you would
do with the prize
give it a wash
all you have to do is go to omaze.com
slow mo guys and enter for your chance
to win if you do win you've gotta email
me a picture or something of you in the
car i can't i can't wait to see that so
to sum up go to omaze.com
slow mo guys for your chance to win a
tesla model s plaid all donations
benefit reverb that's pretty much all
the information you need hopefully you
win i'm rooting for you thank you very
much for watching this video make sure
you subscribe and i'll see you in the
next one goodbye